بعد أقل من 24 ساعة من صدور قرار للأمم المتحدة
يهدف إلى الضغط على
الحكومة الإسرائيلية والجيش لإبطاء
هجومهم العسكري في غزة، صدر
إعلان من قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
بأنهم سيوسعون بالفعل
جهودهم العسكرية ويكثفونها، وذلك
بالانتقال من شمال غزة حيث يتواجدون هناك.
ويقولون الآن إنهم قريبون بشكل أساسي
من السيطرة العملياتية على
الأجزاء الوسطى والجنوبية من غزة، وهي الأماكن
التي يأوي فيها مئات الآلاف من الأشخاص
النازحين من
منازلهم ويعيشون ظروفًا صعبة للغاية
من شأنها أن تجعل
جماعات حقوق الإنسان أكثر صعوبة.  في
الأمم المتحدة، نظرًا لأن الناس
يتلقون الآن إشعارات بأنهم بحاجة
إلى الإخلاء وإعادة التوطين مرة أخرى،
يتم إخبار العائلات التي نزحت أكثر من مرة وأحيانًا مرتين أو ثلاث مرات أو أكثر أنه
يتعين عليهم العثور على مكان آخر آمن للذهاب إليه
ولكن  الناس في الأمم المتحدة، بعضهم على
الأقل يقول إنه لا يوجد مكان آمن
للذهاب إليه في غزة، دعوني أقرأ لكم هذا الاقتباس
من توماس وايت، رئيس
وكالة الأمم المتحدة للاجئين الفلسطينيين، الذي
يقول إن الناس في غزة هم أناس
ليست قطعًا على رقعة الشطرنج، لقد تم
تهجير الكثيرين بالفعل عدة مرات،
ويأمر الجيش الإسرائيلي الناس فقط بالانتقال
إلى المناطق التي تشهد غارات جوية مستمرة،
ولا مكان آمنًا ولا مكانًا للذهاب إليه،
وأضاف أن هذا يأتي الآن في الوقت الذي
أعلن فيه جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي عن مقتل
مسؤول رفيع المستوى في حماس رجل
تقول إسرائيل أنه كان يساعد حماس في شراء
الأسلحة من أماكن أخرى
وتهريبها إلى غزة اسمه حسام الأطرش
وبحسب الجيش الإسرائيلي فقد قُتل
في غارة مقاتلة أه خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية أعلنوا ذلك
يواصلون جهودهم للبحث عن
رئيس حماس وغزة يحيى سنير وشقيقه
محمد لكن إسرائيل
تحرز بعض التقدم كما يقولون بما في ذلك
في الأيام الأخيرة تدمير
مجمع أنفاق ضخم تحت الأرض كان يضم
أه مقرات ومكاتب وأماكن سكن
لكبار قادة حماس لكن لا  أه
لا يوجد قائد لحماس نفسه وهو
أمر تقول إسرائيل أنه سيتعين عليها
تحقيقه قبل أن
تنتهي هذه العملية العسكرية سوف
ريبلي سي إن إن في تل
أبيب